- How's your boyfriend?
- He's great.
(upbeat music)
- So my name is Ben,
and I was together with Linda
for about a couple of months.
- I'm doing this just because
I like kinda doing weird things.
- I don't know why I'm doing this.
- I think my ex is great.
- She's great, you know.
She's really sweet.
- I'm Alex, and I was dumped hard.
- My name is Whitney, and I was with
my significant other for six months.
And I dumped him.
- So the way she broke up with me was
she said that she just
wanted to be friends.
- I feel like I need to
clear the air a little bit,
because I think I was
made out to be a villain.
- So I made this song
called Let's Just Be Friends
and put it in a music video
that I made on YouTube.
- This freaking music video about me.
- It was really cathartic,
actually, to make that video.
- That kinda rubbed me the wrong way.
But, you know, good for him.
I watched it, it's kinda catchy.
- [Linda] I'll be the little spoon.
- [Ben] Thank you.
- You're welcome!
I won't emasculate you.
- Oh, this is so wrong.
- Yeah, it's like Survivor Wednesdays.
- Oh geez.
- Should I like embrace?
Do you want to like, actually like--
- Just do it, just do it.
- I feel like we never
did this when we dated.
- Not that, yeah, you're right.
- How's your boyfriend?
- He's great.
This is gonna be awkward
to have him watch.
Sorry about this.
I don't, I'm, oh my God.
- Do you remember what we fought about,
what started that fight?
- Nope. Don't remember.
- We fought over a light bulb.
And I wanted it--
- We fought over a light bulb?
Was it the light bulb that
was hanging from my ceiling?
- No, no, it was like the blue
one outside your apartment.
And I wanted it off, and you were like,
no, I like it on.
And I was like, I feel really insecure.
And you were like, why
do you feel insecure?
And I was like, because I feel
like you don't want me here.
And you were like, you were like,
I don't want to be in a relationship.
And I was like, that's what I thought.
I would have broken up with me
if I'd been you back then.
- Are you still ticklish?
- Yeah, don't--
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
- Was I a rebound?
- Yeah, most definitely.
But I rebounded after you,
and that was like a shit show.
- I am a lot to handle,
and you couldn't handle it.
I'm sorry.
- Did you regret breaking up with me?
- For a little bit, yeah, I did.
I felt like I had let a good thing go.
- A compliment for this lovely gentleman.
He makes me laugh very
hard, and it's very nice.
- I remember I didn't like the sweater
you wore on our second date,
but I was like, whatever, it's okay.
And then like you--
- Was it the blue one with the collar?
I love that sweater.
- You're very unique,
and I have not met too
many people like you.
- It just looked kind of like pretentious.
- Oh.
- (laughs) This feels so good to say, Ben.
- [Ben] See you!
- This feels so good!
I hate that sweater.
- I'm sort of sorry...
that it went down the way it did,
but I'm glad you got success
from your music video.
- And you know what,
we wouldn't have found
two new people that we're like happy with.
- Exactly, exactly.
- And that's nice.
- Some things aren't just meant to be.
- Yeah, you know, it wasn't as
bad as I thought it would be.
It was, it was kinda nice.
It felt good to reconnect.
- Yeah, it was not as
bad as I anticipated.
- [Linda] Yeah.
- Didn't hurt.
- That was fun.
It was fine. It's not that weird.
- High five.
- There you go, high five.
That's nice.
See, we can high five now.
- Mm-hmm, we couldn't
do that two years ago.
- You do some cuddling, you
get a high five out of it,
who doesn't love a high five.
Am I right?
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Yeah, that was two in a row.
- Why not? What's wrong with that?
- It's awkward!
- Why, it's just a high five?
- We're good.
See, we're fine.
- [Alex] Cuddle.
- [Whitney] But be careful.
Cuddle with protection.
- Use condoms.
- I'm not saying have sex with your exes.